porque tras meses de batalla para tomar
esta localidad ahora Rusia decide
retirar aparte de sus tropas esto es
real o podría ser una estrategia del
kremlin
Valentina Me parece que pueden ser las
dos cosas evidentemente a zelensky a
Ucrania le interesa mandar el mensaje
que en pajmut pueden estar recuperando
recordemos que ha sido un dique de
contención especial en el área de dones
entonces me parece que lo que pueden
estar haciendo por un lado es mandando
ese mensaje y lo que puede estar
haciendo el kremlin es pudiendo
reposicionar sus fuerzas a partir de lo
que pudiéramos decir es ya lo que ya
hemos se esperaba de primavera y verano
en la recomposición de este conflicto
Bueno y qué está pasando en estos
momentos con el grupo Wagner hay
distanciamiento con el kremlin
mira en la realidad pareciera que no
pero obviamente lo que pueden estar
enviando es un es un mensaje que hay un
distanciamiento esto lo que puede
generar Valentina es que haya un un una
un pensar de un reposicionamiento de
Ucrania pero en la realidad Wagner le
conviene estar cerca del kremling Porque
si se aleja del kremling en ningún
momento va a tener cercanía con ningún
otro país entonces me parece que puede
ser y y es mi cercanía respecto a este
posicionamiento que Wagner lo que está
haciendo es también un reposicionamiento
y su cercanía con el kremling es más
real que nunca bueno llevamos semanas
hablando de una posible y esperada
contraofensiva de Ucrania que falta para
que materialice esta respuesta
me parece Valentina que lo que necesita
kiev es más apoyo de occidente
evidentemente lo que tiene
Ucrania no le alcanza no le alcanza y
por eso en la presencia de celenski en
la Cumbre del g7 el hecho mismo que
macron el presidente de Francia salgan
estos momentos a dar a dar declaraciones
es como para que decirle occidente nos
tenemos que posicionar más porque con lo
que tiene todavía no le alcanza aquí es
para poder reposicionarse sobre todo en
esta área de bascut que es lo que
necesitan retomar es importante para
Ucrania y es lo que le están pidiendo
occidente Ayúdanos para poder recuperar
respecto a esta retirada como se está
mencionando de Rusia